well anyway as i said our plan is to
wrap things up over the next three weeks
and then re-emerge at some point on hbo
max
and what we're gonna
what the tony tony that's really
distracting what are you doing
oh hey conan uh sorry about that i was
just uh thinking about your new show
well no you weren't actually you were
painting a birdhouse
and i've told you several times not to
do that while you're at work
yeah tell that to my extremely impatient
etsy clients
oh now that i've interrupted you could i
ask you a series of questions about that
new show you're doing
well you know actually i don't think we
have question number one
what is hbo mex yeah is that like only
available in mexico or something
no it's not mechs it's hbo max oh
hbo max hbo max
[Music]
she's homeless i'm sorry is there a
problem tony i just didn't know your
royal highness was too good for
uh regular old blue-collar hbo you know
so i guess whenever
us working-class slobs want to get our
fix of emotionally complex
high-production value prestige dramas
we've got to slum it over at hbo with
the rest of the
scum while a code in old fancy pants
rides the elevator
up to the hbo max penthouse no it's it's
not a fancier version of hbo anybody can
sign up for hbo max on their computer
ooh a computer the governor of fancy
pennsylvania thinks everyone's walking
around
with their own personal computer
actually yeah these days most people do
own a personal computer tony yeah and
tony didn't you just say that you have
an
etsy shop who are you neil degrasse hole
tyson
stop policing my logic right there okay
hey hey hey calm down tony
listen hbo max is just the name of hbo
streaming platform that's it
streaming oh okay i see yeah
it's like pp we got it tony which comes
out of your penis
yeah so there's two things that are
humorous to imagine hence the laughter
yeah okay is there anything else tony
yeah can i have your hbo max password
no no it it only costs like ten dollars
a month yeah ten dollars a month
plus the cost of a new boat yeah i
don't know why you'd need a boat just to
watch hbo max tony
well i already got a boat for watching
netflix about for watching hulu
and another boat for watching hulu plus
now i'm supposed to get a fourth boat
for watching hbo max hey
i'm not made of money even though i do
have a roll of quarters lodged in my
intestine from that one time
i bet the crew guys 200 i couldn't
swallow roll the quarters
p.s i also ate the 200. tony
tony time for us to get back to work and
speaking of work aren't you
my cameraman where's your camera oh it's
uh
it's over here somewhere you know don't
worry i got you framed up nice
looking good boss you're really terrible
at your job tony you shut your mouth
andy richter
i will put a forklift in you one more
word
one more word tony the cameraman
everybody
god take it easy anyway we got a great
show don cheadle gonna be here stick
around we'll be right back
you get too upset tony i love don oh you
do
yeah the marvel movies are great okay
we've done other stuff too you know
hotel rwanda i love all the marvel movie
season
i said hotel rwanda man there's avengers
okay avengers age of ultron all right
what about boogie nights that's a great
film
i like the one where he's in the suit
armor flying around